wow look at this baby shower camp
i can't wait to go there's gonna be poop
that's not much of a party planner so
we'll see how this goes
can't wait to eat it yeah
hi i'm hannah i'm the world's okayist
mom and i am super
pregnant now the one outstanding item of
my pregnancy that i have yet to address
that i don't really want to address is a
baby shower it's not my thing
i'm not really into baby showers for
myself but you
asked me to let the boys plan my baby
shower and honestly
i like that idea it sounds fun i'm gonna
do it i'm gonna see what they come up
with and
wish me luck but first the rules there
really weren't
any rules but more guidelines of what
the kids were allowed to choose for this
baby shower so
they not only chose the venue but they
chose the color scheme
the theme the food decor and my outfit
i feel like i know my kids really well
at this point so i wasn't worried about
too much i actually had a pretty good
idea
of what they were going to choose for
this baby shower with the rules in place
i handed everything over to matt and the
boys to start planning
all right guys so we kind of have to
make a decision on the baby shower
okay that's not much of a party planner
so
we'll see how this goes where do you
want to have it
at home no no
yes there's gonna be poop
like i know this about my kids i know
my kids well enough to say with a
hundred percent certainty
they're going to pick poop what should
the theme be
poop at some point in the day just hope
it's nobody pooping their pants
what color should we have the balloons
white black
yeah but usually you choose like pink or
it's baby girl or baby boy but black
it's my favorite title
it's your favorite color now keep in
mind at this point
i don't know what they're doing i don't
know what the plan
is and so for me the most difficult part
was hearing them discuss it but not
having a full understanding of what
is going on and not being able to
intervene
and make things work all right what kind
of food should we have
oh what about hot food like other foods
but taco bell spaghetti taco bar
their choices are gonna be a little out
of the box hey guys
so we have a little problem you know the
paletas you wanted to
have for mama's um uh-huh baby shower
well we can't have them because they're
going to melt we can't get them and
there's no place to keep them frozen
and cold what do you think we should
have for dessert
so what kind of cake poo poo poo poo
poo poo there's gonna be
poop uh okay you want poo poo cake
that's the theme right
i just hope they don't try to make matt
bake
anything or decorate anything don't tell
mad i said this
but i'm better at cooking a lot better
at cooking
sorry matt okay so i looked online
and i tried to find a cake you know for
a poop themed cake so i found a cake
where
you sprinkle graham cracker crust on
there and you get chocolate candy to
make it be like a kitty litter box since
i don't bake i went to the store and got
a chocolate cake
wine and i are going to sprinkle some
graham cracker crust
this is like when i was spreading the
gravel around the front yard
pretty good at this this is perfect
or should i say perfect so
it's finally here the day of the shower
and the boys
got to choose my outfit hey boys
can you pick out my outfit okay
what should i wear hmm
this one this one
this one this one
a little bit of backstory on that dress
it actually
was the dress i purchased when i was
previously pregnant
i had bought that dress with the
intention of taking maternity photos or
something in it
before i had a miscarriage and so i've
worn the dress since i actually wore it
in
the instagram mom video but it felt
weird to me at first wearing it for my
baby shower
because seeing that dress and wearing it
for the baby shower also made me realize
that i miscarried last december
and i'm due this december it never
dawned on me
how coincidental the timing of all this
is
it made me really grateful to be doing
it this time
around and being so far along feeling
really
good about everything and everything
going so smoothly for me
you look amazing he's getting so big
i know very comfy thank you
the boys went ahead of time to the
shower and i drove separately
first thought was this venue is nowhere
i've ever been before
so i was kind of surprised by that
because i thought they would choose a
very familiar place
or even have the shower at our own house
when i pulled
up to the venue it all made sense the
place itself is called la la land
playground
and it's a really cool hybrid of
eating area jungle gym arcade
plus party space i think the kids were
planning the seed
of where they want to have their
birthday parties this year and so
they're like
mom isn't this place great
i see what you're doing so matt walked
me into the venue
and unveiled all that they had worked
so hard on
oh my god oh my god
it was very them
the theme the theme is black
who did this
i knew there would be poop i called it i
knew there would be poop
the first i was like i know no matter
what there's gonna be poop somewhere
and there was ample poop everywhere my
kids could have gone a lot further with
the poop theme it could have gotten a
lot grosser
i feel like they kept it pretty tasteful
so i was impressed
so the vibes i got upon entering
immediately were funeral vibes
because the color scheme they chose was
black
which i definitely think that color
scheme threw the venue
off because they're used to hosting kids
parties so it's probably like pink
purple blue orange so
they clearly didn't know how to
complement
the black decor and they ended up
putting out white roses
which just gave off even more funeral
vibes
now for the food of course there are
spaghetti tacos as the main course of my
baby shower
welcome to my life it really forced
people to try it
and i think a couple people got on board
with spaghetti tacos that day
so to complement the spaghetti tacos
naturally
the kids chose mexican corn
it's my corn to me this proves
that they love me and they think of me
because
if you remember a previous episode we
shot where i showed what i ate in a day
each trimester
i do eat that same corn in that video
because it's been one of my favorite
foods throughout this pregnancy
oh man this is my favorite food
now let's talk about the cake that cake
was a masterpiece
honestly i was so impressed matt
must have done it and he managed to pull
that together
so artfully i want to like embed this in
my brain forever
i cannot believe they made it i was
proud of him
nice variety of soup so now
matt is the designated cake decorator of
the family
congrats to you matt you've gotten a
promotion
from observer what really surprised me
was the kids came up with a couple
activities to do at the baby shower i
imagine matt helped them
find these first up was onesie
decorating
with fabric markers and onesies at every
seat
at the party and guests were encouraged
to decorate their own onesie
now whichever onesie the boys determine
is the best
will be the outfit that the baby wears
home from the hospital
sorry kid now the other thing the boys
came up with was a name jar for people
to write down name suggestions
and put it in the jar to try to help
matt and i nail down a name we are
not drawing a name to choose the winner
to name the child
but hopefully there would be some good
suggestions at the end of the baby
shower
and we just can't agree if matt had his
way this baby would be named biff
that's what i'm working with okay now
i've gotten a lot of comments a lot of
messages
suggesting that i let the boys choose
the baby's name i've already floated
this by them
their name choice for both genders has
and always will be
chad between chad and biff like what am
i supposed to do
somebody help this venue actually proved
to be
the perfect space for having a baby
shower that allowed
children because the kids just ran
non-stop they were at the arcade on the
play place in the ball pit
playing all over the place just going
going going going going and non-stop
they did take a break to participate in
some of the activities and did decorate
onesies
and it was really sweet and fun but for
the most part that venue is one of those
places where
you just let your kid go and
forget about them until it's over
how's it going special guest at my
shower alex traeger
she's one of my best friends we call her
my daughter um
because we're so close she's always
there
through everything and so i was really
glad that she was at the shower because
she is besides me the number one person
to go along with my kids crazy antics
she texted me the day of the shower
saying
is the theme poop
i feel like baby showers are typically
handled by
the mom and the mother-in-law and
friends
so i think for my mom it was hard to
take a step back and let somebody else
plan my baby shower but
she was very proud of the boys choices
and did say that it came together very
nicely
so we got mom's seal of approval there
now what are my overall takeaways from
this baby shower well first
this is probably the most unconventional
baby shower i've ever
attended which for our family i think
fits really well what a baby shower
means to me
is letting my kids have fun and
celebrate their new brother coming
and connect with my friends and hang out
and have a good time and not have all
this pressure or stress around making
things
perfect the unintended benefit of
letting my kids take the reins was i was
already
expecting it to not be perfect from the
start i had that pressure alleviated
from day one
and it was amazing it allowed us to
actually just all come together and hang
out
in a weird space for a baby shower
but it ended up being so fun it was just
like
come hang eat some corn eat a spaghetti
taco
that's not real poop you can eat that
cake enjoy yourself
and for anyone who you know needs inspo
for a baby shower theme
poop works really well so that's all i
got for today i'm hannah and if you had
a baby shower let me know the theme in
the comments or what it was and what you
played
please let there be someone else out
there who had poop as their theme so i'm
not alone
now if you'll please excuse us we're
going to
draw names from this jar and hopefully
find our
child's name till next time
poopy butt yep feeling good
[Music]
what kind of things should be there
should we have like poop emojis
yeah poop emojis all right what kind of
food should we have